definitely yeah for a guy or girl anyone
no or both either or
I mean I would say for a guy yeah it's
kind of a little weird you call them in
cells but I would say for a girl if
she's 21 and she actually is a virgin I
think a lot of guys would probably not
believer but if if they know that to be
a fact they'd probably find that like
really attractive you think so yeah you
think you think a virgin girl is
attractive I mean I think if a girl's
attractive she's attractive no I'm
saying you're being distracted to a man
I would say so hmm you were going to say
something you were like no no I'm not
saying what he said wasn't right about a
guy I find that attractive if she was 21
and a virgin but I think
all my friends lost their virginity like
at like 14 or something 15 and then I
remember I lost my virginity like a
couple days before my 18th and I
definitely felt like no one directly
pressured me or all my friends weren't
like oh go and do it but it was kind of
like you did feel like a ticking Time
Bomb because it did feel a little bit
like
where when everyone's doing one thing if
you're doing something different you
feel a bit weird so it's like when I was
coming up to my 18th it did feel like I
was getting to the weird stage oh really
you felt yeah I felt like awkward like
you have to get it done yeah
but I can't put my finger on where that
come from I guess it's just the norm
because the average
um age of people losing their virginity
is actually around 17. oh okay see
compared to like everyone I know that's
really late do you wonder if
um
those numbers are based on like an older
generation because I just hear stories
from my my younger sisters about like
their friends tell us the stories pal no
no I'm not talking about anything with
minors sorry no sorry no no no no
um but I'm there's just wild stories
when they're doing stuff where like like
at a much younger age it seems like then
the older generation so you think
there's more pressure on like the
younger generation to lose it and I
don't even know if it's pressure I just
think they're Wilder like I just think
they're exposed to more younger and I
think that like my mom's generation
would say that about my generation right
like it seems like every generation is
just getting Wilder and Wilder and
Wilder so a lot of times like when I see
the stats it's always based on like five
to ten years ago and I'm like it's a
whole different group of kids so I
remember when I was gonna lose my
virginity I'm not gonna lie as a guy
like I prepared
because like you as a guy you kind of
prepare like you know what's going to
happen I knew the day I had my
girlfriend she had already had sex I
hadn't but I never told her that
obviously because I was experienced and
um like you just prepare for it like it
was that the same was it like a was it
something that you kind of fell into or
something you prepare for
for me personally I fell into it oh
really okay yeah it wasn't it wasn't a
preparation it wasn't it was just sorry
um yeah no it wasn't it wasn't yeah I
didn't prepare for it as as you said
yeah but yeah no it just happened
organically you guys did you prepare I I
definitely prepared for like a month
like mentally and like spiritually
absolutely prepared uh and like in my
case it was very similar what you're
saying is I didn't want to be the only
one in my friend group who's a virgin so
I just found the first girl who had a
crush on me and like just begged her to
let me hook up with her and she was
super enemy so she's like yeah totally
and I prepared for it right because
talking to women was never easy right
right and so yeah it definitely was
something I had to prepare for
how do you prepare for this yes like is
it do you get some condoms and watch
YouTube tutorials by condos
like look for advice on and this is like
over a decade ago right so this is like
yeah it was a long time ago and I I was
just trying to mentally prepare for the
most part and um did it help definitely
definitely I had no idea what I was
doing I just like stuck it in just
waiting for something to happen I was
just confused it was very very confused
has it got better tough
did you have to prepare over there I'm
not married so I couldn't tell you guys
he's a virgin we got a virgin on the
show no I don't know if I like prepared
but yeah it kind of just happened but I
already kind of was wanting it to happen
actually the very first time I had the
option to do it it I couldn't make it
happen I was like too nervous and the
girl was older than me she wanted to and
I just couldn't
right not being descriptive here but uh
yeah I just couldn't get hard I was like
too nervous I was really young yeah like
really young how young really young I
think I was like a freshman in high
school I don't know how well that is
over here um 14. no I was like 12 or 13.
yeah yeah girls had crushes on me when I
was young and then um but yeah it was
until later it was probably like a year
and a half two years later
after that wow wow
we go to Catholic school and I feel like
the girls would feel guilty like after
if they lost their virginity to be
honest like just in my friend group I
guess
so that's what God like I definitely did
because I was older I was definitely the
last one in my friend group but like I
felt so guilty because I felt like God
was like mad
he's still mad I know I know I know he's
doing that so
that pressure at 12 so I just want to
kind of Flesh it out like where did you
think that came from like where did it
because at 12 to me a 12 year old would
be thinking about different things other
than sex I was probably like 13. she was
a junior so she was probably like 15 or
16. she was just like an older girl to
me like the a year or two makes a
difference in high school right you know
and then she was like she's already done
it she was experienced I wasn't so she
was like 14. her she was probably like
15 or 16 I don't know yeah okay yeah
um I don't know you're just never done
it you're nervous you hear about it you
see all these adult films and you're a
kid and you're like yeah back then
actually we didn't have the internet
like you know I'm 34 I forgot to mention
earlier but I remember like when we were
in elementary school someone found this
adult magazine right from their dad and
they ripped out a page so we used to
have to walk home from the bus stop and
there was like this desert where we'd
hide this one picture just a still
picture of a girl with her boobs and
like we were all like young kids staring
at this thing and we'd hide it back
under this rock throw dirt on it and
like we'd stop by there like every day
to look at it so do you think like your
introduction to like losing The
Virginity was
probably not healthy was something like
that like because I think a lot of guys
like even me like I had I was introduced
to like a corn videotape when I was like
13. that blew my mind it's so young to
me I'm like this is like sad no
literally like like I had a friend and
he was at his house and he knew he was
older than me he was like 15. I was like
13. and
he knew that his mother had like a corn
video that's his VHS times like she had
like a VHS and he was like guys there
was like three of us and I was like guys
I'm going to show you something and um
he put the tape on and that at that at
13 that literally blew my mind yeah one
of the greatest days of My Teenage life
was fun
like everything changed so I have a
question for the guys
um would you want to marry a virgin
definitely yes yeah as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible